yeah I think for the talk Moe I
definitely think you were right in that
uh status symbols are relative to this
society and they sort of shift as the
culture shifts and I think in certain
certain societies like Silicon Valley we
see this new form of status symbol in
like virtru signaling so practically
telling someone that you wouldn't wear a
jewelry can just be as of a status
symbol of a gratification in certain
societies as wearing that piece of
jewelry is in others so I'm not accusing
you of doing this I love your talks and
all of your content but I was just
wondering is there a lot of ego
gratification behind what you're doing
here because you're talking to you're
talking to millions of people
and I was just wondering what you feel
when you give those talks it's a
wonderful question thank you so much for
this question so so the reality is you
will never be equalized okay again just
like the truth hmm so we would never be
without ego because if you wear a you
know an Armani suit it's an ego that is
attempting to say hey I've made it I'm
successful I'm stylish if you wear
shorts and t-shirts it's another ego
that says I don't care about those
things right you know the the game here
as I always say is that you own your ego
and it doesn't own you right so you know
the difference when you start to find
yourself aching if you if they don't
believe your ego but if you start to if
I wear a t-shirt and people said and I
start to feel that people are telling me
no no no you're not really that simple
and straightforward you're just
pretending to be and it hurts me then
I'm actually try that then this actually
is an ego that I'm trying to prove right
now I I rarely say this publicly but I
promise you I promise you if you really
want to fulfill me I would love to reach
a billion happy and be forgot mm-hmm I
would absolutely Anna and by the way
part of the design of a billion happy of
two people telling two people telling
two people is truly me saying this is
not about me at all yes and it's not
about any other leader it's about every
one of us becoming ally
you know and that is so critical to the
success of this right I have been
working on my ego I promise you actively
actively for the last seven years we
again today I spent most of the day with
friends and I can tell you there are
three that I'm still aware of that I'm
trying to kill 1 billion happy is not
one of them this is totally not about me
okay this is believe it or not even not
about Ally the this is about us yes it
is for the first time ever I am not that
driven executive that wants to achieve
and just have a TED talk right as a
matter of fact I swear if you really
want to reward me when we get there he
raised my name because to me this is not
about this level anymore I'm not playing
for this level anymore I'm playing
because I tend to believe that the way
this world should operate and will
operate will be totally different if we
get to that target and that's what it's
all about
mmm oh yeah yeah that and by the way for
everyone who's here and everyone who
will see this video if I ever show any
sign of that thrash me wake me up and
remind me okay because it's hard huh
it's hard when I get so many wonderful
messages when I get hugs and I get so
much love it's hard not to sometimes
tell yourself whoa-ho
yeah well done mouth right if you ever
see one of those signals thrash me in
public
right wake me up because that would be
the worst thing ever remember it's all
about the why than the what then the how
if my why goes wrong this is never gonna
happen I think the way you just
Illustrated achieving a goal of helping
civilization out past this level past
your life and then erasing the name
afterward I wish not to be too don't be
too I think if people embodied that that
would be very helpful for where we go
yeah good question great question thank
you
so Moe you mentioned the the idea of
intensity being it almost felt like
negative in your view in the workplace
and I kind of wanted to ask what's the
the use of that intensity because
obviously you have to be an intense
human being to get to this point you
have to be committed to what you're
doing to get to this point
how does intensity not show itself you
choose very good journey you choose what
it is that you have to do we where
intense because we plug into our life
way more than we should be doing right
so most most successful business people
need one or two deals a year most sales
people work on 60 or 50 or 40 or 30 or
whatever that number is most of us are
intense because we're splits you know
spreading ourselves over the wrong
targets over the wrong objectives right
now once again there is an enormous
value to commitment right but there is a
tremendous value to chill I I don't know
how to to stress that enough the game is
to do your absolute best in whichever
task you assign yourself as an important
task you'll be very selective about what
you assign as important right and then
you do your absolute best spiritual
teachings from that from the east we'll
call that detachment the attachment is
to do the absolute best that you can and
understand that the result is a little
bigger than you that you could spend a
year and a half working on a deal and
then the CEO changes right happens it's
outside you or you know what I call it
in install for happy I call it committed
acceptance committed acceptance is to
understand that the results achieved in
your life are a little bigger than you
are
go ahead you wanted to say something
else
like for me the the a lot of times I hit
points when I look at software that my
coworker and my boss is written and and
I'm like that could be better
objectively I can sit down for a half an
hour and point out to you why that could
be better and I need to be intense in
getting that point across because they
won't understand it if I'm pretty casual
and I'm very comfortable about getting
that point across because it feels like
a comfortable thing for me I'm okay if
it doesn't get done I'm okay if it does
get done where is that intensity you
said that you ever ask yourself if it
needs to be better I'm storing a social
security number for a person who cannot
defend themselves against an attack from
someone who is well more resources
that's not better that's not better so
I'm not talking about necessarily better
I'm talking about this needs to be
different because there is a different
is a very different word so so if it's
not right you need to set it right okay
but you wouldn't need intensity for that
at all if you just simply say hey guys
this is not gonna work it's not it's not
as intended right the reason when we
want intensity is when we disagree right
is when you when you think of it as this
is not good enough and they think of it
as this is better than good right that
disagreement is because we haven't
aligned on what matters but in reality I
will tell you hands down if you have an
accurate view of something that actually
is not going to work no one was know no
one's gonna object to that I mean I
learned that heavily at Google so at
Google I'm sorry I really know I really
am because I know you're in a highly
another dog intelligent people who are
willing to say I'm wrong I'll accept
that you are right about this and all
back down I'm working with people who
are normal
who were gonna say no you were wrong I'm
not gonna back down
well where's Dayton all of this I'm
sorry what is data in all of this where
is the data who lost on them so I mean I
I understand like and again this is
another environment where it's I am in a
perfect environment where people
understand that this data is sensitive
and it needs to be protected and I don't
need to be intense about this but I'm
trying to understand where do you say I
am gonna put my foot down I am right
here it's like about being happier not
happier I know that this is the right
thing and people are gonna be unhappy
about it okay so that right I will tell
you hands down in front of everyone here
everything I told you today I don't know
if it's right or not okay as a matter of
fact I work from the assumption that I'm
never right believe it or not okay I
work from the assumption that I know
nothing at all hear me out so the idea
here is all I know is I have a slightly
different perspective right with a
complete humbleness that my slightly
different perspective on any topic
whatsoever might actually be right and
might be wrong right if you have that
humbleness in mind you will make your
point of view and then you will say does
that make sense right you're not going
to prove anyone right or wrong because
no one is right or wrong by the way
that's the whole point everything is
within context now if you manage to get
to the point where we say before you say
you're right and I'm wrong if you get to
the point and I learned that so well at
Google if you get to the point where you
say what are we trying to optimize for
here what does success look like right
if you achieve that first yeah but but
that's the problem if we don't agree on
that then no one is ever right and no
one is ever wrong because within context
they're solving a different problem
right so so the number one I did and by
the way what I loved most about Google
most when I joined that company was that
I was the vice president I sat in those
meeting rooms and the youngest people in
the audience or the in the meeting said
mo you're an idiot I mean they didn't
really have to be that right ya know but
another though they said it that way
like what you just said is a pile of
crap and I was like oh why can you
please tell me why right and then two
minutes later someone else stood up and
said hey what you just said is a pile of
crap right and the whole concept was
what are we trying to measure if we're
trying to measure something and we agree
that this is what we're trying to
measure finally we're approaching the
truth right if you're not approaching
the truth then basically everyone is
wrong or maybe everyone is right and it
doesn't need intensity at all because if
you walk from that work from that
assumption that within my context I'm
right within their context they're right
- okay then suddenly the conversation
becomes a conversation of what I really
want the best out here I'm just I'm just
trying to tell you guys there is
something you're missing out on and if
you don't take it into consideration
that's fine I'm gonna try again to get
more data if it doesn't work I'm gonna
try again and get more data if it
doesn't work maybe I'm wrong hmm that's
fine and I and I have that very weird
habit in my life I give everything
stretch two or three strikes I never try
the fourth time ever so everything in my
in my life relationships you know
everything everyone gets three chances
you no one ever gets four ever so if I
if I give you something three times and
you say no okay yeah
some people don't even give you a second
chance three is fair
yeah just saying some people don't I
think what you said about the both
perspectives being interesting to say
could they be true in their own
perspective and then keep working on
getting to some source so illusion so
one also one of the biggest reasons for
unhappiness in our modern world is what
I call the six grand illusions right
that we treat the modern world with a
view of things that with concepts we
believe are true but they are actually
illusions
one of the biggest illusions is what I
call the illusion of knowledge is that
we actually think we know right even
though we constantly get proven to not
know enough that there is more to know
or that what we knew was not very
accurate the earth is flat no the earth
is round
no it's not a sphere it's actually
egg-shaped it's you know rotating around
the Sun I don't know if you know the Sun
so many of us will actually look at and
say I am absolutely certain that the
earth is going through an elliptical
orbit around the Sun no it isn't as a
matter of fact if you really want to
know the truth the Sun is moving in an
in an orbit the Earth is going around it
so the reality is that the earth is
actually going this way it's not it's it
never touches the same point twice or
not not for ages right and because the
universe itself is moving and the galaxy
is moving there's absolutely no one that
actually understands what the orbit of
the earth is right but we simplify it
and we say with certainty
I'm sure it's elliptical yeah good for
you if you just humble enough to realize
that what you know is not true all right
hi my name is Jackson and thank you so
much for coming out today and talk about
happiness is a very applicable topic in
today's society so thank you so much
very well
my question on to give a little bit of
context so my younger brother is in high
school and he is recently I've had a
conversation with him in terms of what
makes you happy what makes you and other
peers happy and a lot of it relates to
technology whether it's playing digital
games video games online Instagram how
many likes you get on an Instagram photo
Twitter Facebook
chat etc so my brother he recently one
of his friends committed suicide
recently back in October and a lot of it
had relation to how technology relates
to happiness so I guess my question to
give you that ask context my question is
what kind of advice do you give to an
older brother and a parent for someone
who's going through adolescence in their
relationship with technology and
happiness wow that's a great question so
I I need to answer it in three layers as
a matter of fact so to start with there
is an issue the dependent definition of
happiness when you ask your brother what
makes you happy happiness we defined as
the peace we we have the calm we get
when we're okay with life as it is that
is never found in activities of pleasure
just let me explain that quickly huh so
pleasure or fun are the are weapons of
mass distraction right they they
basically are out there to stop your
brain from solving the happiness
equation long enough so that you can
find your default setting as a child if
your brain is not solving the happiness
equation if it's not returning to you
that something is wrong you think that
you're happy but the reality is that the
minute you go back to thinking you're
unhappy again right so that constant
distraction is our attempt to not solve
the problem it's almost like taking a
painkiller when you have a headache
there is a reason for the headache by
taking the pain color you're not solving
the problem at all you're just numbing
the pain for a while once the the
effects of the painkiller wear out you
go back to the or headache right so
truly what you want is to find out when
are you calm and peaceful when are you
content when are you completely rested
relaxed chill when one when I
you're not striving to be in another
place right this is truly what happiness
is now we have to realize that those
young adults are going through the
toughest time of all of us it is so
difficult out there you have so many
choices none of them are right there
have so much pressure right and it's
just not
none of the promises are being fulfilled
- at all are being fulfilled that or
they're being advertised too heavily
they're being swayed all over the world
all over all all over life and and it's
just really really difficult now what
that means is that we need we we
actually should never take their answer
on face value and I I i will say that by
the way to all of your friends not only
your younger brother but everyone you
know especially in America I beg you
if you ask someone how are you doing and
they say I'm fine don't just don't take
it on face value mmm we need to start
digging digging deeper no really how are
you yeah yeah it's like so tell me a
little bit about how last week was you
know aha actually listen to nin care
right as a matter of fact I would even
say next time you tell yourself I am
fine ask yourself no really how are you
right it's like you know how when you
start to catch the flu you go like this
doesn't feel right I need to do
something about it somehow when we start
to catch unhappiness but like okay
that's fine I just need to go through
another day now
that's number two number three there is
nothing wrong with technology or fun if
we're already happy so the challenge
with technology with distraction
sometimes with watching a comedy with
playing a video game is if you're using
it as a painkiller to mask the pain
right if you're using it as a supplement
when you're already happy there's
nothing wrong at all right so what I've
learned through my life again through
Ally my son and an heir my daughter who
is an incredible sunshine herself was
that when your urge to engage in fun
activities is coming out of need then
that's a very very clear call to action
it's like I'm trying to escape the
problem here I'm just popping pills to
distract myself if I have already
discussed the problem with myself or
with others found my piece and then went
on to play a video game when I'm totally
peaceful that's like a supplement that's
like you're taking your vitamins in the
morning when your brain is already calm
you're even giving yourself more reason
to enjoy life there's absolutely nothing
wrong with that the distinction between
those two truly comes with two exercises
and I beg you to do this everyone in the
room one is be the expert understand the
truth about happiness understand the
truth about unhappiness understand how
you can generate those feelings on
demand and then be there for others be
there for others fully fully like really
truly connect by work believe it or not
if you asked me to boil my approach to
life to one sentence the one thing I
know that solves every challenge I ever
get is I treat others as I like to be
treated
it's as simple as that so if I am
feeling down how do I want to be treated
I want someone to hug me I want someone
to sit next to me and when I tell them
no I'm fine
I don't want them to leave me right I
want them to sit next to me I want them
to connect with me at a human level
right please please PLEASE invent invest
in your own happiness until the point
you become an expert and I will tell you
I swear to you it's predictable it's
like an engineering problem and when you
get there just make sure that you treat
others like you like you want to be
treated make them happy it's the
happiest thing you can ever do to
yourself
yes can I can I ask another can I add
another layer so for parents by the way
and whenever you become a parent success
as a parent is defined if I make
children successful that's the wrong
target right every parent in this room
should learn or if you ever become a
parent learn that the target is a lot
more sophisticated the target is if I
make my children successful and happy
right if I make them only successful I
failed if I make them only happy I have
failed
the target is I can make them both at
the same time it's ending those two
right and again when parents ask me how
do I make my children happy I remind you
that you can do you can tell your
children anything they're never gonna
listen the only way you can turn you can
teach your children anything is to be
that thing if you lie to your children
and say don't lie right they will learn
to lie right if you want to if you're a
control freak your children will grow up
to be a control freak the only way you
can teach your children to be happy is
to be happy yourself to be the example
of that happiness thank you so much for
the discussions been really inspiring
my question is humans are inherently
social beings and as we see from all ape
species we used to live in very small
societies and with Dunbar's number the
estimate that humans are in like 150
people is our social circle with
industrialization and being in a city
like San Francisco we know that it's
really hard to find our tribe and in
some ways that grab for ego is our way
to try to become the upper tier tribe
right and so there's this longing for
belonging that I think our society and
the lack of connection has really kind
of disintegrated how do we balance the
desire to belong in seeking out that
happiness versus being an individual
so one of the most interesting tricks so
by the way nothing makes you happier
than being with people that you love the
people that are you know challenging you
but interesting you but you caring for
you and you know social connections are
so so important to our well-being to our
progress as as a species to our success
and
and you know an advancement my simple
trick is this if you want people who
you'll if you want to find people that
love you and who you love do the things
you love right if you start to do the
things you love the people who are
similar to you will show up at those
places so if you if you love tango go
dance tango you will probably find other
tango dancers there it's really not that
complicated right having said that there
is an interesting challenge between
belonging and fitting in fitting in is
an ego challenge okay it's it is a
challenge of me trying to make others
approve of Who I am right
belonging requires no approval belonging
is I feel home when I'm next to you
right I feel at my best I feel relaxed I
feel that I belong here and by the way I
could be very different than you and it
doesn't have to be we don't have to fit
in together to to belong as a matter of
fact the best belonging is when you
belong to someone who complements you
not someone who just agrees with you as
you are right and by the way I never no
one will ever I can just guarantee you
that no one will ever approve of you
ever ever right if people approve of you
they're disapproving of themselves
that's the problem
so people fight for their own egos and
if you're perfect then they're not so no
one will ever say you're perfect okay
the problem is you actually don't need
anyone to tell you you're perfect
because you know what you're not none of
us are right as a matter of fact the
beauty of this artistic piece that we
are is that it's not perfect that it's
so dynamic and flowing and changing and
certain roads you know it's amazing that
we actually think that the target is
perfection the target is to become the
best gamer that you can become
right and the best gamer that you can
become is very different than the big
the gamer I can become and none of us is
perfect right
so I sum it up in two things find people
who are wonderful hmm who don't who you
don't seek approval from would do all of
the things you love and if you if you
get there hang on to them like your life
depends on it right there is that
interesting statistic of like yeah your
social circle circle can can extend to
150 people I know thousands of people
thousands right where I will meet them
the next time and sometimes I would have
to consult with my contacts to remember
their name but I remember everything
about them you know how I remember
everything about them I pay attention
totally pay attention next time we meet
test me I will remember you eat the
color of your hair and the question that
you asked right and if that's what you
want from others give them that then you
start to belong together and I really
really believe that if you treat people
as you are as you like to be treated
more and more good people will come your
way and treat you the way that you treat
them hi mo my name is Dana thank you so
much for coming here tonight and for
writing the book my question is about
many of us have people in our lives or
have experienced people who seem to
thrive on unhappiness yes and some of
those people may even be related to us
yes so do you think or do you will think
that there are some people who are
unable to be happy these are two
questions so are some of us unable to be
happy some of us have have been
programmed so badly to the point that it
is extremely difficult but everyone is
reprogrammable so so I I always compare
happiness to fitness unless you
disabled I mean if you're fully able you
know your body is capable you can become
fit right every one of us if we eat
healthy and you know and and work out
four to five times a week if we're able
bodied we can become fit right for some
of us however it is a lot more difficult
than others right if your muscle mass is
a lot as a lot less than it where it
should be so the furnace in your body is
not what burning calories properly so
your metabolism is very low if you're
you know in a carb cycle that you're
unex unable to escape from all of that
makes it difficult for you makes it more
challenging for you but that does does
that mean it's not possible that you
become fit no we've seen so many success
stories of people who were way
overweight and then became super fit
similarly with happiness so happiness is
there is an element of it that is
logical there is an element of it that
could be spiritual but there is an
element to it that is physiological
right our bodies start to to to to to
produce imbalances whether on the
positive side on the bed or the negative
side by the way so fun for example is
addictive because fun you know puts
dopamine in your blood
dopamine by the way is a you know an
excite excited right it excites you and
it's much more addictive than serotonin
but it actually removes the serotonin
from your blood which is the hormone
that gets produced when you're calm and
peaceful which is when you're happy
right on the other hand if you're
depressed there is a very different
chemical imbalance and so that makes it
so much more difficult for some people
to get back to this on the logical side
you can take cultures as a whole you
know German culture or Eastern European
culture or Dutch culture or whatever
where we are trained in those cultures
to be critical we look for what's wrong
with everything in those cultures and so
the happiness equation is by definition
broken because if you look for what's
wrong you're going to find it and so no
event is going to meet your expectation
right and so there are
our cultures however that are hyper
optimistic and you know easier to find
happiness because they're looking for
what's good about everything and so
events most all you know most frequently
meet or miss or or beat expectations so
first question is first part of the
question is are some of us unable to
find happiness no and unless you're born
with a different operating system you
know then then you're probably going to
be able to go through the same process
to find happiness for some of us who are
you know far down the path of
unhappiness it's a little more difficult
now let's come to the question of those
who are our relatives or parents our
brothers our sisters our boyfriends our
friends who we feel obligated to who are
destroying our happiness and I will
answer with one simple thing that they
tell you on aeroplanes attend to
yourself first before you help others
right if you really want to help them
become happy you need to become super
happy and resilient so that they cannot
affect your happiness negatively because
if they affect your happiness negatively
you're never going to be able to help
them that's that's task number one when
you get there I beg you to understand
that what you all people in your life is
love care and respect if they're your
children you also carry odom support
right love care and respect does not
mean you owe them your life right so I'm
gonna use the extreme example if your
mother is chronically focusing on
everything that's wrong and always
always grumpy right you owe her love
care and respect right love care and
respect means that everything you do
with her is flooded with love it's
caring and giving and it's respectful so
ally was the master of this it was
amazing my my wonderful wonderful boy
but his mother was not annoying at all
his mother was an incredible woman
I still believe she's amazing right the
best mother best woman amazing
she as a mother had so many emotions
that would push Holly you know to
achieve something or something whatever
so she would go to him and say honey I
want you to do this it would go like why
mommy why why did you want me to do this
and she would say whatever and you would
go like but mommy I don't want to do
this daddy it's so important I want you
to do this and after a few backs and
forth he would say something that
completely blew me away every single
time he would hug her first and say
mommy I'm not gonna do it but I love you
right every single time you could see
her melt it's like okay baby you don't
have to do it right every single time
what he was giving her was not his life
he had his own life to take care of
including his happiness but he always
did that with love care and respect
right now for those people in your life
that you cannot take out of your life
give them that but don't give them your
happiness if you give them your
happiness
you're never gonna help them and you're
gonna drown with them right and and the
game here is that you need to be as
healthy as you can so that you can help
them out that was a great answer thank
you so I want to refer to a couple of
points you've made one is about rain
having no inherent value the other is
the happiness and suffering are these
reciprocal cycles and I guess the third
is time we can only perceive time if
we're outside of it so these are all
reminding me of like a Zen Buddhist
philosophy which is you know wiping away
all these illusions and trying to name
things and understand them in order to
just arrive at the truth which is you
know existence or you know this this
sort of undefinable thing so for you 1
billion happy or this future state where
we all
arrived at this truth I mean what does
that look like to me it feels like it
could be a moment of worldwide
recognition you know together stopping
this kind of cyclical motion what do you
think so if every spiritual belief I
mean Buddhism always comes up but every
spiritual belief I've studied so I've
studied almost all of them to a very
very you know it's you know to great to
great depth every one of them is all
about two things one one is alleviating
suffering right and the other is truly
about connecting with something bigger
than you are but was something bigger
than your physical form and and they all
come at it from different ways but one
of my absolute most pleasurable studies
which I've done for years was to
actually find what's common across of
all all all of them and what's common
across all of them is wonderful they all
reflect that so so beautifully to say if
you follow these physical forms
abilities you're probably gonna miss a
lot of the truth right and if you really
want to perform in life in a way that is
peaceful safe you know respectful to
others and happy then you need to see
behind the illusion when you when you
when you however imagine that this is
doable right how does it look like and
every one of those beliefs I think
Sufism and Buddhism are actually quite
similar in that approach they call that
insu and Buddhism they call it nirvana
Taoism and so on in in in Boonton Sufism
they call it dying before you die right
nirvana actually in definition is to
wake up and see right it's almost as if
saying this physical form or navigating
actually is the dream that waking up
from that dream
you start to realize that what-what-what
is in the dream if you haven't seen
inception please see it with that in
mind huh where we're living in Inception
were living in that dream constantly
we're at level 4 or in such right and
and and to wake up and see when I was
answering the question about ego is my
ultimate dream and my ultimate dream is
to persevere in life with zero
attachment to life that is to find the
truth to find the truth and my view is
to see that all of those illusions don't
really matter that what really matters
is that I connect to you because you and
I are part of that bigger thing that's
outside the physical form were only
separate in the physical form if you
want right if I can connect to you in in
in truth without judging you without
wanting you to be better or worse
without expecting anything from you and
I drop all of the rest of the illusion
if I have no willingness to buy a car
and no a version to buy a car if I have
no interest in a Pink Floyd t-shirt or
hate to a Pink Floyd t-shirt if I just
flow and connect then that is nirvana
right when you get there as the Sufis
say then you have died before you died
you're already there right and that
believe it or not is when you hold the
controller as a video gamer and you stop
thinking you're just in constant flow
enemies show left and right or blocks
appear in tetris and you're just simply
in constant flow with life you don't
think about where the block came from
why is it that block I wanted a
different block you know why is that
enemy shooting at me is there a way for
me to survive you're just in constant
flow right that is the beauty of life
that is truly believe it or not when you
die before you die is when you start
living that's
the only time when you start living when
you realize that it will always be okay
that you're already okay and that
because this is a zero-sum game
it starts with nothing and ends with
nothing and that all you have is that
game is now is this game right and
you'll flow you play and it becomes
amazing that's finding the truth first
of all thank you
I really appreciated your perspective on
mixing science and spiritual and math so
I have two questions in four context I'm
in a transition into my career as a
senior manager and at one point in time
I taught yoga so my goal is to confuse
my management style with the yoga
philosophy and working in corporate
environments and working with companies
where we're making billions of products
and looking at billions of dollars in
budgets I guess one of my questions is
what advice do you have to work in that
environment but also fuse happiness into
the environment and a daily I guess the
daily routine and then the other one is
kind of math related and spiritually
related to Albert Einstein's equation e
equals MC squared so if you're looking
at energy and mass and acceleration
within the human body
I guess what are your thoughts on that
Wow how much time do we have so so your
yoga and all of the spiritual practices
by the way is is constantly trying to
help you a tune with the universe around
you to find that balance so that the
universe works for you not against you
right and and truly I'm not a yogi okay
but I but I understand the value of that
balance whether you're a yogi
at the gym or you are you know in the
you know lifting weights or you're
running a marathon or you're at work
right it's that very interesting so
let's just assume for a minute as a
hypothesis that we can read then later
proof with science that the more you
resist life the more life resists you
right call it viscosity if you want hmm
and start to work with that hypothesis
most of the time when we flow with life
life assists you when when you flow with
business business assists you so one of
the things I used to bring a lot to my
teams and I always had business teams
who are doing massive deals billions of
dollars hmm was if the deal is so stuck
and so resisting have you ever
considered dropping it just finding
another deal that's easy and flowing
right why are you stuck on that idea of
scarcity that this is the only one right
can you actually flow with it mmm when
it's stuck can you ask yourself what is
off-balance the relationship with the
client of balance is my systems engineer
of balance what's going wrong if you
find that interesting balance hmm
somehow life flows with you and helps
you and that you learn a lot in yoga I
mean for those of you I'm sure this is
California so everyone here is a yogi
right you know but you know that the
truth huh you would be in that pause and
it's so so difficult
and then the good instructors would come
to you and fix your ear a little it's
like you know they just push it a little
bit this way and you go like wow I can
do this for half an hour so easy right
and and it really is so interesting when
you think about it that when life
resists us we somehow because of all of
the management books and business books
we've read we resist back good luck with
that right life is mighty you cannot
take it on so so this is one side
mathematics and equations are actually
really interesting so e MC equals e MC
square is not my
favorite view of I I am a huge fan of
the underlying concepts behind the
theory of special relativity or general
relativity the whole idea of time and
our total understanding of time right
and truly if you want to understand for
example when I teach about mindfulness
big big buzzword everyone will tell you
presence is important you need to be
mindful you need to be present in the
present moment you need awareness and so
on and so on and so forth one of my
favorite chapters and so for happy is
the chapter of time and it truly starts
with zero relativity right if Y is
presence so important because if you
truly understand space-time you
understand the slices of time that we
have to go across along the arrow of
time and that the only access you ever
have to any slice of time is the slice
of not of now this is pure science this
is - is best and those and then suddenly
you realize something amazing that the
only time you ever live is the slice of
now right if you're ever thinking about
the past and the future you know what
that is
you're inside your head because those
are not slices of time that you have
access to unless you convert them into
thoughts and then roll them over and
over in your head right to either
torture yourself or pleasure yourself
but you're not living now here's the
interesting thing
so I actually run an experiment here and
I dare most of us if you remove the time
stamp
if you refuse to think about anything
that's that has a past or present tense
on it you will completely fail to find
an unhappy thought other than thoughts
of physical pain so I feel cold can be
in the present moment every other
thought that makes you happy or unhappy
is time stamped with past and future
right that's so interesting but it is
because the only life
you ever lived is now everything else is
a thought and every thought can lead to
unhappiness
right when you start to think about this
one use so many example I achieve avoid
math completely huh I am other than
chapter 14 which is hyper mathematical
the rest is just very simple very
complex scientific concepts explained
very simply and that applies to
everything you know if you have read in
the same columns black swan for example
I use a lot of blacks want to talk about
about the illusion of control right you
know and so on and so forth I I and by
the way I feel a reader please read but
if not all of us are readers please
watch the videos I thought every concept
of this book to Stanford at Stanford and
its online for free available it wasn't
my best work it was very early but it
still gives you every concept just
promise me that you're going to put in
that one hour a day three to four times
a week just like going to the gym and
don't watch my content only watch Deepak
Chopra or you know a curt ollie or all
of those other masters that are teaching
us so much but just spend an hour a day
until you know that you've completely
grasped that topic of happiness and
you're doing it well thank you so much
one truth that I've internalized is in
the form of a poster that I have in my
home and it says we're not meant to be
happy all the time and it's something
that reminds me that when I'm going
through a period of unhappiness that
it's temporary but I want it but what
you told me today or what you said today
made me think that maybe we are meant to
be happy all this absolutely so where no
one is ever always happy because
basically that would shut down your
survival mechanism right so pain as much
as we hate it is good for you right if
you cut your finger without the feeling
of pain you wouldn't protect it right
pain is good for you to cut your finger
over and over that's not right right so
emotional pain is good for you emotional
pain is something's wrong I need to do
something about it emotionally it's not
about physical pain
unhappiness is it there is a big
difference between pain and suffering
suffering is unhappy as
on demand it's recreating that pain over
and over right you're not you're not
supposed to be in that state at all
that state depletes you it doesn't get
you to do the right decisions and it has
no impact on the real world whatsoever
it doesn't change anything what changes
have anything is that you stop being in
that state and you start moving to a
state where you can actually take action
this is when the word starts to change
now one of the biggest lies of the
modern world is you're supposed to be
unhappy it's good for you it makes you
learn it makes you change direction what
is good for you is pain that what this
is what makes you learn and this is what
makes you change direction right Ally
dies the pain is real
it makes me leave Google and dedicate
the rest of my life to this right as
harsh as it is its pain is good right if
I close my door and cry every day that's
a waste of my life that's that's the
suffering taking over and wasting my
life it's not necessary it doesn't need
you to anyplace good so do you think
that when you're not happy you're
feeling pain it's also so here's my
here's my deal so a lot of people say oh
are you always happy no I'm not and I
know people who are close to his
Holiness the Dalai Lama
who is my happiness idol and he's not
always happy right as humans that the
reality of you of our or of of this
existence is that suffering is real
right it's it's a survival mechanism so
it's going to be triggered every now and
then what I measure surprisingly is my
rebound time such an interesting measure
yeah I measure my rebound time every
time I feel unhappy my number one
measure is how quickly did I acknowledge
it just like acknowledging when I catch
the flu right and then how quickly did I
manage to go back to happiness
now I'm daring you here with the
exception of three to four times a year
where it takes me a little longer my
rebound time is normally in seconds
seconds from the time I'm aware that is
that I'm unhappy to the time I actually
completely dismiss that topic as not
worthy of my unhappy
right I'll give you an example today in
the morning right we-we-we I was driving
- - from San Francisco to Palo Alto to
clear my storage right as I arrived in
Palo Alto I realized I forgot the key to
the storage right an hour and seven
minutes after I left my hotel I can sit
there for the rest of the day cursing my
life right or I can simply smile turn
around
drive back get the key turn around drive
back clear the storage turn around
drive back and come meet you right in a
very interesting way it was so simple
for me to say what if San Francisco was
four hours away or two hours away
instead of one hour away from from Palo
Alto I would have been totally okay with
it
right it's just that I set my head at
the beginning of the day that it's going
to be an hour and ten minutes that is
causing me the problem and there is
absolutely no problem Hertz gave me a
very nice car this time so I was driving
happily it was enjoyable I had a friend
we had a wonderful chat everything was
okay right
that is a mindset hmm it has nothing to
do with what Doyle gave me gave me but
truly I imagine once that feeling of I'm
upset that I forgot the key comes up I
acknowledge it and I tell myself what
good is that takes me seconds most of
the time to return back to let's just do
something about it now that is what the
skill is all about does that mean I'm
not going to feel unhappy tomorrow when
I'm a little stressed going to the
airport I will and it will take me a few
more seconds to get it back to
perspective all right maybe one last
question well if you really want maybe
maybe we can squeeze you in - hi I'm
Brad thanks for being here inspiring
challenging etc let me give you a tiny
bit of backstory so I do a lot of
research and work in the area of gender
norms and so your conversation focuses a
lot on at least what you said today on
the individual so I'm worried wondering
about your thoughts on like societal
norms and entities and how like from
like you know like in gender norms it's
not the same of course with happiness
but they're similar like you know we're
taught like girls should behave a
certain way boys should behave a certain
way and so we're sort of almost
programmed from from birth pretty much
so I'm curious about your thoughts on
how societal norms and entities and
schools and governmental organizations
play into the whole how can we as
individuals be happy when we have these
quote unquote higher powers or sort of
fighting against us it's incredible when
you think about it that gender is an ego
do you realize that so I actually had
that and so for a P and my publisher
wanted to take it out but the reality is
that identifying as a woman or a man a
boy or a girl is truly a form of ego
right because I will tell you
hands-down I am as much woman as I am a
man right as a matter of fact if I look
at a leader like Gandhi I think Gandhi
was more a woman than a man right the
problem we have is that we started to
define our feminine and manatee and
masculinity in gender and body parts and
janitors it's like it's really really so
shocking now every single one of us has
a bit of this and a bit of that it's the
ego conditioning that makes you embrace
one more than the other and it's so sad
as a matter of fact I will call on every
woman in this room and say that the
biggest problem one of the biggest
problems that our world has today is
that you're still continuing with that
ego condition it's amazing to me that
there is so much beauty and value to our
world in the feminine right the feminine
attributes of us empathy of compassion
is actually sometimes viewed as
masculine because it involves action in
it but empathy intuition you know being
able to connect communication skills all
of those incredible feminine qualities
that we learn not to embrace not in our
personal life not in the workplace not
in our relationships right because we're
so conditioned to believe that they're
wrong
that they're bad
the irrationality and I say that with
love and respect women have that
incredible ability to be intuitive they
see so much more than you know a person
who embraces the masculine whose which
is hyper linear can see right but then
we call that irrational it's not
irrational it is just a wider view of
the same truth and because we call it a
rational we give it we give it a
negative name suddenly it becomes a Bubo
and we don't want to show it right and
believe it or not one of the most
incredible things that led to my success
and my whole career is I constantly
insisted to have a 50% share of feminine
in my leadership and I encouraged them
totally to be women to show up and
sometimes be emotional and sometimes
tell us what we're missing and sometimes
connect to others and so on and so forth
so I as I said I'm writing several books
at the same time which I know it sounds
weird one of my favorite pieces of work
I'm doing now is on the whole problem of
diversity part of a book that's called
soul for happy at work and that whole
concept I call it the CPC the character
profile chart that whole concept of
trying to tell you and tell everyone
that each of us has a little bit of
every attribute that every human has and
that by the way there is no two of us
that are the same there is no chart that
says this is a woman and this is a man
there is a chart that says this is you
and another one that says this is you
and a third one that says this is you
and and one that says this is me and now
the explosion of gender identity freedom
is starting to make that so clear right
and so if you actually follow those and
start to tell yourself I don't need to
abide by anything because there is no
ego definition of who I really am
suddenly it all goes away and suddenly
you start to play to your strengths and
suddenly you start to bring your
strengths to work and that I believe is
the first time where we will actually
empower the feminine not empower the
woman's body
view right because what we're trying to
do today is were taking women to work
and telling them behave like men so that
you succeed so while you have the body
of a woman we don't want the feminine
attributes we want you to be competitive
aggressive forceful you know linear
strategic all over the masculine
attributes and by doing that believe it
or not we're actually killing the
feminine more now is the feminine
agender attribute not at all I have I
know men who are more women than many of
the women I know right and you can see
now this is flourishing around the world
you can see men who are embracing that
feminine energy in them you can see
women who are embracing the masculine
energy in them and you can see people in
the middle who don't want to identify as
either and you can see people who are
clearly men but are also feminine and
the other way around all right let's do
one last you want to take the last
thought go ahead go ahead and take the
last thought oh you had a question back
there so this has to do with pain and
seems pretty easy these days to to find
something it's that's painful in the
news you know I've recently you know
kind of like disengaged with Facebook
because it's like hmm
there's so many ways to sort of
reincarnate and and help them but at the
same time it just costs me so much to
like stay engaged so brilliant that
you're making this comment yes and so I
just you know wanted to put it out there
to you it's like one of the things that
I see is this the use of resources you
mentioned we're not resource limited you
know and I see all these people that's
like we have the resources why can't we
just do these things right to
that's a great question so so here's the
truth huh
the truth is today's media in whichever
format online offline you know TV
whatever they have one target and one
target only which is to keep you stuck
in front of them for as long as they can
because you're the product right if you
follow you're gonna get stuck in two
interesting ways one is you're gonna get
frustrated like hell and at the same
time we're going to be convinced that
your frustration is worthy that you're
actually making a difference you're
making no difference whatsoever so if
you're for Trump or against Trump right
the last two years of your life have
contributed nothing to American politics
whatsoever right you've just burned
yourself from the inside out and you've
contributed not-- change whatsoever now
the reason for that is you and I can
only champion one cause at a time
because it is so I am championing 1
billion happy I am extremely passionate
about clean water and anti slavery right
and I constantly get people that say
more I want you to talk to me and work
with me on this and I say I love you so
much and it's so important to me and I
want to support you 100%
but I can only do 1 billion happy now
right the real question is this you
start from what it is that you are
actually going to champion and then shut
everything else out everything
everything else is a waste of your life
total waste of your life that's number
one number two is please tune into your
emotions and start to acknowledge what
happens 11 and a half years ago I
realized that my heart was becoming
black enough to constantly see people in
Hollywood movies pointing a gun at
someone else's head and shooting and my
heart wouldn't move but I cried out loud
that my heart became
so numb I refused to watch those movies
anymore right
I took it I took charge of my own purity
my own engagement in life and I said my
role in this is I'm never gonna champion
any of that again if you do that too and
everyone starts to do that Hollywood is
gonna produce comedies right so you need
to every one of us needs to do two
things one of them is to say my number
one mission in life is me I need to
clean this I need to attend to myself
first before I help others that's number
one
anything that affects me negatively
anything that really takes away from
that real me that I am I'm gonna take
out one by one and I guarantee you if
you take one a year one a day out of
your life you have somewhere around 17
years to go right there are so many
illusions in the modern world that you
can take one a day for the next 17 years
and you will still have a few more to
work on right nothing wrong with that
it's just that well so do you know
deluded by the modern world
number two is in terms of your impact on
the world champion one see it through
and then champion another right whatever
that one is for you it could be you know
animal rights it could be you know the
right for gluten-free pasta for a
homeless people whatever it is that you
feel is important champion that one shut
everything else out because you truly
have no impact on anything else zero
impact they're lying to you by making
you believe that you can change the
world
hmm you can only change the world in
what you decide to champion that
Browsing now on because we're technical
here I use hyper accurate tools to limit
my engagement on things that are not
good for me so I own my phone I have
things like stay focused or RescueTime
or other tools you know I know the
pixels now have them you know where I
basically allow myself less than 12
minutes on Facebook every day
right I have to be on Facebook because
of my mission right I allow myself 12
minutes there every day I allow myself
somewhere around 44 to 42 minutes a day
depending on the day on what on LinkedIn
LinkedIn is a lot more effective in my
view now you may ask me why 42 and not
40 by the way it's just being playful
right and and and that idea of not
taking myself too seriously but those
things are things that you actually have
to start taking seriously to tell
yourself CNN now right Fox no right and
so on and so forth
all right one last one last question
so um more you know my story I became
much much more positive because of my
experience and it took probably decade
because we have to unlearn so much in
our lives it requires a lot of practice
to get support to become a habit
probably as a closing note what would it
take for people to implement this on a
day to day basis for it to become a
habit for them to practice in order for
them to eventually inspire others to
become like them and and solve for happy
that's one and given the fact that we
have to unlearn so much are we better
off focusing on self or happy at schools
because the years to unlearn are much
less than adults beautiful question so
to start with again let's go back to the
analogy of happiness and fitness right
the first week at the gym is horrible
the second week is much worse the third
week you want to kill yourself right and
then it starts to get better right for
some of us it's our lower body that's
very weak for some of us it's our chest
and back and so on and so forth what
I've realized from all of the people
I've spoken to and you know the people
that read the book is that most people
will come back so what I follow here is
a model that I call 675 so for 18
concepts that you need to understand
most people will come back to me and say
it was one or two concepts that were
causing me 95% of my unhappiness for me
specifically
it was the illusion of control and the
blind spot of labeling right these were
my two biggest challenges that were
causing most of my unhappiness right
once you define those you focus on those
a hundred percent a hundred percent of
your time is to fix those two or one
right when you fixed it the rest becomes
so easy the problem is we try to fix all
of them at the same time when you you
know when people come to me on Fitness I
say your number-one target is to fix
your card cycle if you fix your carb
cycle a lot more things come in place
right for others I would say your
number-one target is to fix your muscle
mass right if you fix your muscle mass a
lot of other things will fall in place
so once you know that one thing
everything else at the gym becomes easy
right so my ask of people is to actually
browse for a while take a week to a
month to browse to listen to understand
and then when you find something that
truly read you know registers with you
note that as something you want to work
on and then go back and work on on on on
fixing this 90% of your time until it's
fixed everything else will fall is our
school is a better place to start I will
tell you hands down so 1 1 billion happy
is a directional target I will tell you
hands down I will not stop unless I
completely fail
right or until I actually get happiness
to be part of our basic education I find
it ridiculous that we have to learn
geography but not learn happiness and
well-being right now so but yeah but but
I will tell you hands down I'm not
qualified I am not qualified so so I
taught I speak to teens onwards because
teens are young adults and it's way too
much responsibility for me as someone
who's not educated in child psychology
and other things so I'm seeking
assistance from others who are good at
this right it needs to be a joint
project between me and others who
understand I mean we were talking about
k12 others who understand what in this
content and how what language should we
use to approach children
we will get there my hope is that we
will get there but I cannot do this
alone I truly need some experts to guide
me through so that so that I actually be
end up being a positive contributor not
an experimenter with such valuable you
know lives that the three are our future
I'm envisioning happiness as part of the
educational curriculum and that's making
me really happy
thinking yes that I think that we are
all part of the 1 billion happy I think
we are going to continue sharing the
message with other people making it more
of a part of our lives our daily lives
the conversation and mo so remember the
promise tell to people who will tell to
people who will tell to people please
yes and and and please be kind enough to
send a happy wish to ally he truly truly
deserves it he was the kindest man I
ever knew
thank you so much for joining
[Applause]
yeah